>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Guha Shankar: Today,
it's December 20th.
We are recording this interview
with Dr. Lotsee Patterson,
enrolled member of the
Comanche Nation of Oklahoma,
emerita professor at the
University of Oklahoma,
founder of the American
Indian Library Association.
We are here in the
Jefferson Studios
at the Library of Congress.
I'm Guha Shankar,
Program Specialist
at the Center and
I'm here with --
>> Judith Gray: Judith
Gray, Head of Reference
for the Folklife Center.
>> Guha Shankar: So,
thank you very much,
Dr. Patterson, for
being with us.
It's a real honor and a
privilege to have you here,
and great seeing you again.
>> Dr. Lotsee Paterson:
Thank you.
>> Guha Shankar: Okay.
Well, we're going to go into
some details of your career
and your involvement with
libraries and providing services
for Native American people
here in the United States
and your reach, which
is vast and wide.
Just for the record, I would
note that you are a graduate
of the Oklahoma College
for Women in 1959.
You have earned your Master's
Degree in Library Science
and Doctorate Degree in
Educational Technology
from the University of Oklahoma.
You are a professor
emeritus of the Library
and Information Studies at OU
and you taught there
for 17 years.
Awards are too numerous
to mention
so we'll merely append a PDF
of all of the lengthy list
of your accomplishments in
the interview transcript
at some point, when
we get that up.
>> Dr. Lotsee Paterson:
Thank you.
>> Guha Shankar: But a long
and distinguished
career, to be sure.
And again, it's a real honor and
a privilege to have you here.
Maybe we might begin by asking
you some biographical details
as to where you were
born, some details
about your childhood growing
up in Apache, Oklahoma.
Then, we can move into
other areas and talk
about your career, if
that's okay with you.
>> Dr. Lotsee Paterson:
Well, where I was born
and raised really accounts
for my career and why I went
into Library Services
focusing on American Indians.
I was born 1931 -- I'm very old
-- December the third, 1931.
So, I grew up in an
allotment in Oklahoma --
we don't have reservations, so
we had little squares of land --
way out in the country, in
1931, height of the Depression,
then the Dust Bowl,
then World War II.
And so, all those things were
dramatic, emotional, hard times.
But my mother was
a college graduate
so I always had things
to read at my home.
Books. She ordered books
from the state library.
I think that's so remarkable.
In 1930s, they'd come by mail.
So, I always had books.
The schools did not have books.
Most of my neighbors
didn't have books.
So, I guess I grew
up loving to read.
When I started teaching
some years later
in a little rural school
with Indian students,
90% of them were Indian, I
realized they had nothing
in their homes to read.
Nothing. No newspapers,
magazines.
Nothing. And I thought
of, I'd describe it
as being a little flame that
started and that kept burning
and smoldering, and I
kept trying at that point,
even wanting to do
something about it.
Skip years later, my life
has been a kind of series
of not being planned but
things just happened.
And after, I had five
kids and I got a divorce.
And I had needed a better job
than that little rural school.
So, I went to a nearby Bureau
of Indian Affairs School,
it was a high school, where
we had a nice library.
But the kids there had grown up
in the heart of the Reservation,
on Navajo and Dakotas, and they
too, you know, had no libraries.
But I worked in the
library while I was there
for an hour or two a day.
And the government, because BI
schools are 12 months a year,
they have to something with
the teachers in the summer,
so they sent me to
library school.
Little did they know I
would never come back.
But then I got a fellowship
and I cannot give credit enough
credit to federal programs
that offer scholarships,
fellowships for students.
I would've never been
able to get a degree.
So, I got a fellowship,
got my Master's Degree,
and since you could take
all the courses you wanted
for the same tuition
because grant was paying,
scholarship was paying
for it, I took 45 hours
on a Master's program.
I crammed it all in.
And I intended to go back to
the BI school but I realized,
with five little kids to take
care of, it was really hard
to work the hours and so forth.
So, skipping forward, I
went to down college of ed,
got an assistantship, I
guess, and got my Ph.D.
In library school,
the Department
of Interior librarian had come
and given a guest lecture.
I mean, all these
things are accidents.
You can't plan them.
>> Guha Shankar:
So, this was all
at the University of Oklahoma?
>> Dr. Lotsee Paterson:
University of Oklahoma.
Right. So, I really kind
of just think things happen
to me and, oh, you know?
But then I followed.
But he came to give a lecture
and I talked to him afterwards
about my concern about school
libraries in BI schools.
That one little short
conversation --
after finishing my Ph.D., I
got a call from the University
of Mexico offering me
a faculty position.
And that Department of Interior
librarian had talked to them.
They had said, "Do you know
anybody who's American Indian?"
It's the days when they
really wanted minority people.
Anyway, that led to my job
at the University of Mexico.
When I got out there, I decided
that I would try to do something
with the Indian schools
out there.
So, I learned all of the
grants that the government has
and I began to look for grants
and found, the title to be,
Higher Education Act:
Research and Demonstration.
So I wrote a grant to
work with the schools.
I had a hidden agenda;
I often do.
The grant was for
training, and --
or, I mean, research
and demonstration.
But I secretly wanted to start
schools in the libraries,
libraries in the schools.
And so I did, and got the grant,
started with some schools.
While I had just started
and I began to get,
we call it the Moccasin Grape
Fund, where word spreads.
There are 19 pueblos
in New Mexico
and two Apache tribes
in the Navajo.
So, they heard about me and what
I was doing and began to reach
out to me, the tribal
people did.
"Would you help us get a
library in the pueblo?"
"Well, of course!"
One of my, sort of,
philosophies is never say no
to something that's
a good cause.
>> Guha Shankar: What years
are you talking about?
>> Dr. Lotsee Paterson: I
started out there in 1972.
So, my first grant was 1973.
So, for the following four or
five years I had federal grants
to work with the
pueblos and helping them
with library services.
I started libraries from
nothing: you know, in hallways,
in food co-ops, in offices.
Because another one
of my philosophies is you
can start a library anywhere.
And I get so irked
when people say,
"Well, we don't have money."
I don't care if you
don't have money.
Do it anyway!
And that's kind of
the way I started.
And they began to
build and grow.
And the pueblo people
really wanted them because,
as they have said to
me, "We now realize --
" and they are much more
culturally pure than Oklahoma
in terms of not integrating
because they're
in these remote reservations
where they are among
their own people 24/7.
Not true in Oklahoma.
So I discovered, in talking to
them, one of them said to me,
"We can no longer live the
way we have been doing.
We must get our children
educated."
And they saw the library as
a way to get them educated.
And they said to
me, "You cannot --
our children are bused
50 miles away to school.
They get on the bus and go home.
They have no libraries to go to.
So, we want a library.
They can go after
school, they can study,
they can do their homework."
Anyway, that's sort of
a little synopsis of,
kind of, the nutshell.
But they wanted them,
that was the thing.
And I always went to them,
said, "Do you want a library?"
and let them tell
me what they wanted.
And I got the most
interesting --
you know, because I hired
people to help teach
and they had the typical
librarian mindset of "Okay,
we'll buy this reference
book and that."
No, no, no.
You ask them what they want.
I got answers like, "We want the
state statutes and state codes
because we don't want to have
to go ask people,
'What does it say?'
We want to know for ourselves.
We want things for our
children to do their homework."
I forget. And, of course,
anything about their
tribe or their pueblo.
First, their pueblo, and
then Indians in general,
they wanted in their library.
But they did have constraints
about some materials,
some well-known authors who were
not Indian who had written books
about them: they didn't want
those books in those libraries
for obvious reasons.
They were not truthful, they
were misleading, and many times,
derogatory, or if they had put
things in there that had to do
with their religion,
or certain things
that shouldn't be told a
certain time of the year.
And it was kind of
interesting, really,
because it was a federal grant,
and the federal attitude
is, "We cannot restrict."
So, I actually got an
opinion from the Department
of Ed's solicitor:
"Yes, you can."
And so that turned out to be
kind of an interesting thing.
But the libraries took
hold, and they grew,
and I had a certain philosophy
that I would provide the
training -- not salaries.
I would not hire anybody
because I knew, if I hired them,
when the grant was
gone, they were gone.
>> Guha Shankar: So, let
me ask you a little bit
about the training part of it.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yeah.
>> Guha Shankar: So,
obviously facilities
and building the library is
one thing, but I'm just --
I really would like to know
-- when you started out,
what was the level of, you
know, professional training
or development available
for Native people
who wanted [inaudible] --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
these were reservations way
out from the middle of nowhere.
And I also knew that you
better do it their way
or you're not going
to be successful.
We had professors thrown off of
reservations because they came
in wanting to tell
them what to do.
So, we took -- I said to
the tribal leadership,
"You choose the person
you want me to train,
and I will train them."
And then I relied on that person
to ask the tribe for some money
to get, like, reference books
and you know, build
the collection.
I had some money I could
build basic, you know,
I could buy some basic tools.
But anyway, it's really -- it
just came together and it grew,
but part of the success of
that was letting them choose
who they wanted me to train,
many times an older person.
And I've learned that that's
good because younger ones want
to work just so long enough
to find another job
where it's better.
The older ones were
vested in the community,
they knew the culture,
they knew the morays.
And so, I, you know, that
was an element of success.
But that, because it was so
successful in New Mexico,
many other places copied,
I guess is the right word,
my proposals and got them
funded in the Dakotas,
so it really carried much
further than New Mexico.
And of course, the
federal agency really liked
that because, so their
money was doing good things.
But the tribes came -- they
would keep hiring this person,
even after I was
through training.
They had enough basic training
they could operate the library.
And I tried to work
with the state library,
and that's very difficult.
Some states will have
nothing to do with the tribes
because they're federal
responsibility,
and the states say, "We have
no obligation to the tribes."
It just varies among the
states, but I worked on those
in New Mexico, and they
were, "Well, they can come
to our training programs" and
so, just many little pieces have
to fit together, but
you have to start
with letting the Native people
tell you what they want.
Many things have
not been successful
because people didn't
know how to approach that.
Well, it was so successful,
and then there was the
White House conferences,
which librarians know about.
We got an Indian delegation;
Department of Interior funded,
helped fund a Indian
pre-conference,
so we got resolutions and
so forth, so we got that fed
into the National Conference,
and after the National
Conference --
White House Conference --
in Rothburys [phonetic] --
>> Guha Shankar: I'm sorry,
Dr. Lotsee, when would that --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Seventy-nine was the first one.
>> Guha Shankar: Okay.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: 1979.
But I want to credit the
National Commission on Libraries
and Information Science.
They no longer exist, but
for a number of years,
they were a federally --
a presidentially-appointed
commission,
and their mission was
to tell the president
and Congress what the needs
for libraries was nationwide.
And that made a huge difference.
The associate director
of the commission,
Mary Alice Hedge-Reszetar, had
been a congressional staffer,
so she knew how to do
the legislative thing,
so after the White
House Conference,
she went to Paul Simon, the
congressman of Illinois,
and said, "Look,
here's some resolutions;
we haven't done anything
about these."
That was all it took.
He called me in, I
worked with his staff,
I drafted the legislation.
You know, like I -- today.
I said, "Here's what I
know the needs to be,
and here's what the
resolutions say."
So, we wrote -- I
drafted the legislation,
they put their stuff, you
know, their lingo into it,
and Simon successfully
got it through Congress.
>> Guha Shankar: So, can
you tell us a little bit
about what's in the legislation,
just as a sort of --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
it basically gave
them some funds.
Not a small amount, but
that's really all it took.
They could match it with some
tribal funds, and then they --
and the salaries that the
librarians were abominably low,
but if you're 50 miles from
anywhere, any salary is welcome.
So, that happened, and when that
was enacted and passed into law
and -- Reagan signed it.
Reagan signed the law --
the U.S. Department of
Ed said, "Wait a minute.
We don't know anything
about Indians."
You know. "What are
we going to do?"
And so they issued an RFP --
I find the federal
government does that,
agencies do that a lot.
If they don't know
anything, they do an RFP.
So, I successfully
got a contract
to provide technical assistance
and training all throughout
the country, including Alaska,
to these places who had
never had this money,
they didn't know what to
do, they didn't know nothing
about libraries, so I
went to states and areas
and held workshops to
write their grants,
and I did a core
collection for them.
One of my problems with
places that start libraries
and don't know what they're
doing is what they buy
and what they purchase, because
they go to a local bookstore
and "That cover looks good"
and "that cover looks good."
So, I tried to do some quality
basic stuff, and that was well.
Then, I negotiated with a
vendor, or multiple vendors:
"Okay, what discount are
you going to give them
if they buy through you?"
And they had never done that.
They don't know how to do that.
So, just typical library stuff.
That was funded for a year.
The Department of Ed couldn't
fund things more than one year,
but they said, "I promise you,
we'll do it for three years."
"Okay." During the first year,
we got a presidential
-- new president.
He appointed new, was going
to appoint a new person head
of Department of Ed,
who said to me --
I can remember, it's like
when Kennedy was shot
and you remember
exactly where you were.
I remember exactly where I was
when that woman came up to me
and said -- it was
in the Palmer House,
in front of the elevators.
She said, "Oh, by the way" --
she wasn't even in office yet --
"I am not going to fund your
-- " I call it TRAILS Program.
"I'm not going to fund it
because -- " I said, "Why?
You don't even know
what we're doing."
"Well, I have five years
to make a name for myself,
and it's not going
to be with Indians."
>> Guha Shankar: Whoa.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
You know what I thought?
"Where is Bob Woodward
when you need him?"
But, she did -- I
mean, she got in office
and she cut the funding
for that, and --
but there's a happy
end to that story too.
>> Guha Shankar: But tell us
about the TRAILS
Program, if you would.
What does that stand for?
TRAILS?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: TRAILS
is the acronym, is Training,
T-R, and Assistance, A, for
Indian Library Services.
And it's still talked about, and
I still hear testimony every now
and then, "We need TRAILS."
I had an 800 number, so they
could call, ask anything,
I manned it 12 hours a day.
And we got -- mostly what they
wanted was basic information.
You know, "How do weA" and they
still need that, even today.
And I hear people saying,
"We need TRAILS back,"
you know, "We need our TRAILS."
And I'm working on that.
I'm working on that.
But it has been enormously
successful,
and I'm extremely happy that we
have libraries on reservations
where there were none.
Hundreds and thousands of
Indian kids have been able
to go to a library.
One other happy note
I'll insert is
when the Gates Foundation
made an announcement
that they were going to --
you know, they have
different focuses.
They were going to focus
on small public libraries
for their grants.
Ah! So, I call Gates Foundation.
I said, "Don't forget
tribal libraries."
And they respond, "Oh, they're
part of the state libraries and,
you know, we'll do
-- " "No, no, no.
No, they're not."
"Well, how do we know where
they are if they're not
on the list of the state?"
"Oh, I'll be happy
to send you a list.
Names, addresses,
and phone numbers."
And sure enough, that took root.
And then it was like
Columbus discovered America.
Gates discovered
tribal libraries.
That's okay, I don't care.
But what they did
was put computers
in those tribal libraries,
sent trainers
down to train them how
to use the computers.
So, I want to give Gates
credit too for their --
you know, that only lasted a
few years, but it's wonderful.
>> Guha Shankar: And when
would that have been, Lotsee?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: When?
>> Guha Shankar: Mm-hmm.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
I can't remember.
Must have been in the '80s.
>> Guha Shankar: Okay.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: And
you know, they only fund things
for a while, but those computers
that Gates funded and put
out in those libraries, many
of them are still there.
I had one, or probably
more librarians
that actually never learned
how to use the computer,
but they've moved on, and the
younger ones have taken to it.
And now, when I go
out to Indian country,
and I go to those libraries,
I say computers have
leveled the playing field.
Now, those people 50 miles
from anywhere can have the
same access to information
that they have in
downtown Albuquerque.
It's absolutely been
such a boon,
and it's bringing people in,
because the people in the --
I'm talking mostly about the
Pueblos, but this is true
in Indian country in general:
they do not have
access to the Internet.
Even if they do, they
couldn't pay for it.
They don't have computers.
So, they can go to their tribal
library and use the computer.
And they do.
And it's brought people
into the libraries
that would have never
been in there before.
>> Judith Gray: So, this was
all prior to your actually being
at University of Oklahoma
in the library school, yes?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, yes, but I continued,
as I still do, to
try to do what I can.
I still get calls from
people asking for help.
Now I get calls about
"Which software automation,
library automation
software should we buy?"
I have to, you know, I
have to -- I never say no.
So, I try to find
somebody in their state
that can give them
assistance or information,
and I'll give them
what they have.
I mostly -- you know,
library journals,
some might publish
just once a year,
the library software companies,
so I'll provide them
information.
I never promote one
company over another.
But there's still many
things that can be done.
>> Judith Gray: Well, I know
that you are funding, as well,
a scholarship for
Native students wanting
to go to library school.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
That's right.
That's what I did at
the university level,
is I write grants
to get fellowships
and recruited American
Indians to library school.
And I'm so happy, I had --
two of the seven Montana tribal
colleges were my graduates,
in Fort Peck, and Blackfeet.
Yeah, I call myself the
mother of tribal libraries.
And like any good mother --
I do have some Jewish
blood too, I must tell you.
My DNA says I do.
So, I compare myself to a
Jewish grandmother who says,
"This [inaudible]
help these libraries."
And I never miss an opportunity
to try to put things together.
I'm a connector, I'm a
networker, and sometimes,
just little things pay off well.
>> Judith Gray: Both TRAILS
and then ATALM, though,
had University of Oklahoma
connections, Associations
for Tribal Archives
Libraries and Museums.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yeah.
>> Judith Gray: So did you
help bridge that as well?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Not directly.
The Department of Ed --
there was some restructuring
and I forget when it happened,
but they took the tribal library
money out of Department of Ed
and they formed, I
think it was a --
when they rewrite
the legislation,
and they formed this IMLS,
Institute for Library
and Museum Services, and they
moved that money over to IMLS,
who's administered,
for some years now.
And so, it's under their
-- and they have --
somebody asked me why
I didn't do this in,
you know, the legislation.
I said, "It's very hard to get
a new piece of legislation."
And Mary Alice Reszetar,
National Commission,
very clever: "We're not going
to make new legislation;
we're going to take a
title under another act
that has been named
but never funded.
So, we're going to
take that title
and rename it Library
Services for American Indians,
but we'll tie the funding
for that to these others
that are funded and it has
to be percent of the funding
that you give to those."
Very clever move, because now
they could not leave the tribal
library title out.
And this is the money that goes
to state libraries, and the,
we knew when that
happened, it was passed,
the state libraries are
going to be very unhappy
because they had always
had flow-through money,
and Mary Alice, again,
said, "No, we're not going
to do flow-through
money with this
because the states
have not worked
with their tribal
libraries, many of them.
So, we're going to direct
Washington to the tribe."
That was a first.
And so, Mary Alice is
responsible for that, and again,
they don't have the staffing
that can provide the
direct technical assistance
and training, and it's
usually very basic things,
like what library automation
system should we use?
Where can we get
trained for that?
They don't know about
buying from vendors,
you can get a 20% discount.
They don't know -- they don't
have access to reviewing tools.
And, you know, I wouldn't
say Google or Amazon,
that's not a reviewing tool.
But they think it is.
So, I still see many issues
that I'm concerned about:
the quality of the
material they're buying,
continuing training,
and of course,
always there's the basic
question of funding.
IMLS just announced this
fall that they were going
to up the basic grants
up to $10,000 a year.
So, that means, these
libraries have, you know,
that's a basic they
can count on.
That's enough to enable
them to continue to operate.
They have trouble -- I was in
Jemez this spring, this fall,
and visited them,
and they were --
their lights were going
to be shut off, you know,
and I took some people with me,
and I said to them, "We're going
to make a donation before
you leave this room.
We are going to make a
donation to this library."
And we got just enough
to pay their light bill
and get the, kept the lights on.
So, I work in nefarious ways.
But always for a good cause.
>> Guha Shankar: So that's
a kind of a very, you know,
drastic aspect of what's
happening with libraries,
which are about literally to
have their lights shut off,
but is there a spectrum of
those kinds of libraries,
ranging from really impoverished
to very, very well-endowed, or?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yes,
and the best tribal
libraries you will find are
in the tribal colleges, and
most of them have MLS graduates,
or they're going to school.
So, they have really
made a difference.
The Dakotas -- Montana has
seven tribes, and at least three
of them have tribal colleges.
Four have tribal colleges.
So, they're in pretty
good shape.
But the other thing
they need is networking.
They need to be able
to talk to one another.
They need to know who they can
call if they have a question
that won't be intimidating.
I have to tell you,
many librarians are
very intimidating.
When you go into a library
and they look down their nose
at you, like "Are
you stupid or what?"
You know, I mean,
now you can laugh,
but I feel that way sometimes.
You know, I've been
in libraries where --
because they get tired of
answering the same questions,
like "Where's the restroom?"
And, so --
>> Judith Gray: Here, too.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: But
they -- with Indian people,
they're so sensitive, not
just to words, but to looks,
to body language, to attitude,
and they can be turned off
like that and they
will never come back.
But I think, more and more, now
that the Institute of Museum
and Library Services is
funding an annual conference
to bring tribal librarians,
archivists,
and museum people together,
and that's wonderful.
And I know you've had
representatives there.
And it's wonderful because
they meet you there,
the tribal libraries and
archivists do, and they're not,
then, afraid to call you.
And they're not intimidated
to ask you what --
they don't want to ask a stupid
question, because you won't --
they don't feel that way about
you because they know you now,
and that's very important.
>> Guha Shankar: So, it
seems to me this training
that you're providing for Native
librarians might also be applied
to non-Native librarians.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yeah.
Well, I believe very much in the
graduate degree for librarians,
but I know it's unrealistic.
And these people in the tribal
settings know things that --
you can train a person with a
Ph.D and they won't know some
of the things these people know,
that they need to be successful.
And I've said, more
than once, you can train
a Native person to be a
librarian, but it's very hard
to train a non-native to
work in a tribal library,
because there's so much culture
behind everything they do
and you know, people
don't recognize,
they don't realize it.
I should give you a bibliography
attached to this interview
of some things I've written
and express those feelings.
>> Judith Gray: If I
can move from that,
you have graciously given us
an interesting collection,
which was a, sort of an
annotated discography
of Native American recordings.
I'm wondering how that
project came about.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Now,
say that again, a little louder?
>> Judith Gray: Sure.
You've given us this collection,
this annotated discography
of recordings.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Oh, yes, yes.
>> Judith Gray: And I
was wondering how that,
how did that come about?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, because professors have
to do research and
publish, that's the truth.
It's not that we want to;
it's that we have
to, to keep our job.
And in fact, I've done that
in my professional career,
but at a research institution
like University of Oklahoma,
you have to publish and
you have to do research,
and I've always focused on the
American Indian library stuff,
and I've been told, "Don't do
that because that won't get you,
you know, what you need to be
promoted," to which I've said,
"Well, I'm going
to do it anyway."
And I've proceeded to
do so, and I got tenure
and I got full professor,
so there.
But I know what they meant.
It was all, the places I've
published have not been
mainstream always,
but it's my audience,
it's the things they read,
like Tribal College Journal.
But anyway, that's, yeah.
But in the context of my
position, another colleague
and I, she was a Ph.D
music professor and we --
I always look for gaps in --
music is a big thing
in the communities
and people don't know this
but certain songs
belong to certain people.
"They're my family's
songs; you have no right
to sing them unless I
give you permission."
And so, commercial
recordings and,
there are many complications
with that.
But she and I took
a look at the field
and there's two major producers
of Indian music: Indian House
in Taos, the other
one's in Phoenix,
I can't remember the name of.
>> Judith Gray: Canyon.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
What is it?
>> Judith Gray: Canyon Records.
>> Guha Shankar: Canyon Records.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Canyon, that's right.
So I went to Canyon and I
spent time in their facility
in the University of Mexico and
we took the, what do you call --
she was the music expert -- off
the, all of the information off
of the recordings and we
put together a discography.
There had been one up
to like 1940-something
of commercially produced
Indian music.
Though we just focused
on the Southwest,
but tried to put together a
comprehensive list of everything
that had been commercially
produced from like 1956 I think
to '94, that gap, that era.
But my colleague,
who had all the data
on her computer, lost it.
So I had one print copy,
which I brought to you.
That's how I met you, in fact.
I brought, I think, I
brought that manuscript.
We had a book contract
but we didn't fulfill it
so I think it's yours.
Do with as you wish,
but it fills the gap
of what was produced.
We learned a lot in the process.
>> Judith Gray: Was she also
at University of Oklahoma?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Yes, yes.
She was a temporary appointment
but she was ill and before,
you know, I was,
and I went to Canada
to be a visiting
professor at the University
of British Columbia during this
era, so I was not there to say,
"Give me a backup copy," and
when I came back from Vancouver,
she had gone and lost,
she lost all the --
and that's a lesson in what
not to do with computers.
>> Guha Shankar:
I wanted to follow
up on something you
just said, Lotsee,
about some materials just
aren't even meant to be heard
by non-family members.
That brings up the
broader question
of the Native American
protocols, which were introduced
about ten years ago, which was
about how non-Native
institutions ought to look after
and caretake Native materials
in their own collections.
Can you talk about that a little
bit and what your reaction
to that set of protocols was?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
actually I'm glad you mentioned
that because a librarian
at the Northern Arizona
University put together a small
group, I think 15 of us,
to write some protocols.
Not just for music, but for
anything intellectual property
that belonged to Indians,
whether design or a song or a,
you know, many elements
of that, and now,
so we put together
a list of protocols
and that's still available.
There's a group now at the
University of Oklahoma,
the Sam Noble Museum,
working on a project.
And what they're
doing is trying to go
out to the Indian
communities and get music
that was recorded
but not commercially.
They're in closets and on, you
know, Uncle John's back porch.
And so, Oklahoma,
University of Oklahoma,
Sam Noble Museum is
working on that right now.
But the protocols
are so interesting,
and when you find people
who have never worked
with a Native group,
they don't have a clue,
and I think the broader term
now being used is cultural
expressions, which covers a lot.
I mean, I've done some work
in New Zealand with Maoris
and they are really leading the
charge with people taking their,
even tattoos, the design, so
hopefully we've created a lot
of awareness and, you
know, T-shirts that used
to copy Indian designs.
But you at L-C are kind of ahead
of that right now;
you're ahead of that.
>> Dr. Judith Gray:
We're trying.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
it's a lot to keep up with.
If nothing else but
create awareness.
Hey, you people out here in the
street, you don't have a right
to take that and put
it on your T-shirt.
It's insulting, for one
thing; it's degrading.
So, good luck to you
all in your work.
But there's many, many more
facets to this whole thing,
and I'm so happy
that LC has you two.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
>> Judith Gray: Thank you.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Because you understand.
>> Judith Gray: Right.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
You understand the
issues and the problems.
>> Guha Shankar:
So, moving slightly
in a different direction.
Today, you came to the
library and you met
with our recently installed
library, librarian of Congress
and the national
librarian, Dr. Carla Hayden.
Can you talk a little bit -- not
actually giving away any details
of the meeting but how did
you come to know Dr. Hayden
and what's your association
been over the years?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, I've known Dr. Hayden
for a number of years.
We served on the ALA
Committee for Accreditation,
I think that was the '80s
maybe, I don't remember.
But our paths have
crossed a number of times.
She was on the IMLS board when
I was on, but I've come to know
and respect her and can't
tell you how overjoyed I
and many other librarians are
to have her in this position.
I met with her today briefly
because I explained to her
that when one of your own, and
I consider her one of our own,
achieves a high, makes a high
achievement or high status,
it's tradition in many
Indian communities
to gift them, to
give them gifts.
So I brought her a gift today.
Happy to know she
liked Indian jewelry,
so I brought her
something from Navajo.
Comanches do beadwork
and I see her more
as a silver and turquoise
person.
But we talked briefly
and very candidly
about some needs
in Indian country.
I didn't even have to
bring up the subject;
she broached the subject
about what LC might do,
so I've got some homework.
I'm going to -- and I'll be
calling on some other people,
see what we can put
together that can make use
of the LC's vast resources.
I'm a big one to
put things together.
I told you earlier,
don't tell me you have
to have money for
it; just do it.
So that's where I'm starting.
I think we can look at various
services and places here
that might piggyback, cooperate,
collaborate, and with IMLS too,
I want to talk to them and
maybe get a revived TRAILS
project back.
Something, an office where
those many tribal librarians,
I spent two weeks in Alaska
in villages along the Bering
Sea, which are Eskimo.
The only way in and out is
by plane, summer you can come
by barge; I prefer
not to do that.
Even planes, which you
look down on the ground,
you see all these planes
crashed down there and,
"Oh well, okay, not today."
But they have a great need up
there and fortunately for them,
the Alaska State Library tries
to provide some services.
So, I think Dr. Hayden
understands the big picture
and I'll be there to
help her if she needs me.
And so will you.
>> Judith Gray: We will try.
Yes.
>> Guha Shankar: So what, so
in your assessment, what is --
you've mentioned a lot of
different needs, infrastructure,
and funding maybe
not so much but --
>> Judith Gray: Training.
>> Guha Shankar: What is,
yeah, in terms of training,
what do you see as the next step
for tribal librarians to take?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
you know I'm not out there
in contact with them daily
but I can tell you
generally what I think.
They still need basic,
basic skills.
And, you know, like searching
and reference questions,
and purchasing quality
materials, all that basic stuff
that librarians learn.
But what I hear at this national
conference and what I see
in talking -- I still
keep my finger you know,
attached with a number of them.
Now they want to know, "How
do I digitize my collection?
How do I start that?
Where do I go?
Who can help me?"
And I would say digitization is
the number-one issue right now,
even for those that
are advanced.
They have some materials
about their own people
they do not want shared.
So they're very reluctant to do
any kind of permanent, you know,
even languages; you've
probably faced this.
There are some tribes that we
do not want our language written
because it's an oral language
and it must be transmitted
that way.
They are so fearful, many of
them are, that if they put it
in writing or they put
it on a CD or a video,
somebody will come and take it.
I can name you many instances
where would-be authors have gone
to Indian people and asked
them to tell them stories,
they go away, and they write
that and adapt it and amend it,
and make it all kinds of,
you know, their own way,
and publish it as an
official Acoma tale,
and it sells like crazy.
New Mexico had several of those.
So, they, they're leery
that somebody will take their
oral history, their stories,
their music, and use it
for commercial purposes.
So, when they talk
about digitizing,
that element applies.
But on the other hand,
and I learned this
at the Arizona meeting because
we have Hopi and Navajo there,
were adamant: "We don't
want, you know, we want this
in our own, we don't
want university archives
to have this.
We don't want," well, if
you just wait, let them talk
and listen, and then
you say, "Okay.
What will you do with it?"
"Oh, well, we have this
warehouse you know we could put
it out there."
"Is it temperature-controlled?"
"No." "Is it
humidity-controlled?"
"No." You just let
them think through it
and then they decide
maybe it would be okay
if your library kept it.
And it would still be ours,
but we can come and use it.
So, just give them
time and be patient.
They realize the value.
You all have heard this
more than I, about languages
that were lost and they come
to a library in an archive
and they find, you're
at the top of this,
recordings of their language.
They have never heard
those words,
nobody remembers them anymore.
So I think more and more
there's a coming together
and it takes special people
like you two that are sensitive,
caring, smart, that understand
this to make that happen.
Where better to keep
this motherload
of material than here?
So I'm an advocate for you two.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
>> Judith Gray: Thank
you so much.
>> Guha Shankar: Well, I was
going to ask you something,
you mentioned something
interesting about,
your travels have taken
you abroad to meet
with other Indigenous
communities.
And generally, where does
the United States stand
in relationship to the Maori
who, as you said, are advanced?
I mean, and I'm not using
this in a comparison scale
but I'm just wondering
what needs to be done.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: No,
that's extremely important,
and I, you know I go
home and do some homework
because I haven't done
this, five or ten years,
but United Nations is trying
to make a declaration,
and worked on it with the
IMLS, one of the legal councils
over there has worked with
them in writing policy
and drafting a language
that hopefully will be
universally accepted.
I actually don't know where
that stands right now,
but United Nations,
and I believe there are some
other international group,
they were pushed, the Maoris
have been very adamant,
the Australian Aboriginal
people have very adamant
about these issues,
and protocols
and ownership, if you will.
But there are other
countries too.
So many times they work in
isolation and they need,
there's great benefit
in joining.
And I actually have not
researched that for a while,
but I think the last thing I
heard was that they're going
to drop that, United Nations,
that they call it
Declaration of --
>> Judith Gray: Of the
Rights of Indigenous Peoples.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Yes, yes.
>> Judith Gray: Yeah, that was
ratified and the US did sign on.
>> Guha Shankar: Finally.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Aren't they still working
with some language and things?
There may be other aspects
of it that they're --
I'm honestly not up
on that right now.
>> Judith Gray: Yeah.
I think there's a
little bit more debate
in the World Intellectual
Property Organization.
They're, they're trying --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Yes, yes, yes.
WIPO? Is it WIPO?
>> Guha Shankar: WIPO, yeah.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yeah.
That's right.
>> Judith Gray: I think that's
where their issues are
being further discussed.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Because people get very,
I've met archivists who
just get livid, you know,
that you don't think this should
be in their archives or, I mean,
they're very territorial,
archivists are.
>> Judith Gray: Who, us?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Librarians are much
more generous.
Well, I understand.
You know, I understand
their point of view.
But we need to get the two sides
together and let the archivists,
and I'm talking about university
and, you know, that level,
not at your level,
where they need
to listen to the Native people.
They'll come together.
But it's a matter
of mutual respect.
You need to respect one another
and your interest and focus,
foci, I guess it
would be plural.
That's a good point, though.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
I wanted to return to this
notion of basic training
for librarians, because you
touched upon something I think
is interesting, you've talked
about a generational shift
from the older generation
of librarians
who might have been older, or
community scholars for lack
of a better word, to people
who got an accreditation
who are younger.
But is that generally the case
that all tribal libraries will,
can afford to have a person --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
No, they can't.
Nor small public
libraries can't.
No, and that's why you
have to be realistic.
I'm a realist.
I realize you're not going
to have MLS people out there.
Sometimes they do.
Laguna has a person who
has graduated, has an MLS
and she came back to
the Laguna community
because she wanted
to serve her people.
But sometimes, coming back to
your own community is harder
than an outside Native person.
I always compare it to
Jesus of Nazareth; you know,
he couldn't go home,
if that makes sense.
So, sometimes it's very hard
because -- I'll tell you why:
because they're very
critical of their own
and they will not criticize
an outside person like that.
I've seen that happen.
I saw it happen at Cochiti.
We had a really bright
young girl we trained and,
but they were, the tribal
leadership would just,
it's different in each pueblo,
but it's usually the elder men,
it's always men, who have
reached a certain status
and they then govern the tribe.
They have different duties.
But I've seen them come down on
her, cultural things, you know?
"You shouldn't do this,
you shouldn't," you know,
and she was sitting there.
Well, that's very hard to
take for a bright young girl.
So it's kind of -- it's a
really good point, though.
What do you do?
They won't criticize an --
even a white person
they won't criticize
like they will their own.
And I've heard an older Comanche
woman explain it this way: "Oh,
honey, don't worry about them.
They're just white people
and they don't understand."
But I think that says a lot.
You know, in other words,
"Don't try to explain to them.
They're just white people;
they don't understand."
>> Guha Shankar: So taking
up your, in the present
in associations with the
American Indian Library
Association, which you were, you
founded, what is its role today
in educating and
training Native people?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, they say, the bylaws
and mission, to assist
tribal librarians
but they really have no
mechanism for doing so,
because AILA, American
Indian Library Association,
is just composed of various
people across the country
who belong to the association.
We do publish a newsletter
and, but we have no ability
to provide what they
really need,
which is one-on-one assistance.
We don't have that.
What AILA should be
is leading the charge
for federal legislation for
amendments to various pieces
of legislation, the
national visibility.
That should be their role.
It's not done very well, I
mean -- well-intended people,
it's done, you know, but it's
just -- everybody's a volunteer,
and nobody has time to say,
"Okay, I'll go for six months
out to Crow Reservation and --
we did have somebody do that,
by the way, to help
them catalog.
>> Judith Gray: So, AILA meets
together with ALA, correct?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yes.
AILA -- the American Indian
Library Association was started
-- it wasn't called that
then but as a subcommittee
to an ALA committee, they would
call it, it's called OLOS now,
Office of Library
Outreach Services.
We started as a committee, a
subcommittee of a committee.
ALA is very bureaucratic,
and later we got to a point
where we could say we're going
to form our own association.
We had no funding base, we had
no, you know, so you understand,
it has to just be volunteers and
-- but there really is a role,
and they will celebrate their
40th anniversary next spring,
I mean, next ALA
midwinter, I think,
here in D.C. They have
had a role, but in terms
of doing on-site assistance,
they just can't do it.
But everything is good, you
know, I mean, there is --
you need associations,
you need groups
that can speak as one voice.
I've seen the power, as you
know, being in Washington,
there's power in numbers.
And I don't know what
the membership is now,
but a few hundred.
But we have many friends;
there are many people
that would help us if we ask.
>> Judith Gray: So probably
ATALM -- the Association, again,
for Tribal Archives
Libraries and Museums --
is that more fulfilling
the needs for training
at this point, do you think?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
It's a great conference
and a great organization,
but it has one purpose,
and that is that meeting,
an annual conference.
But IMLS partnered -- well,
that's funded by IMLS,
but IMLS then said to
the tribal libraries,
"Here's your basic grant,
$5000, but then you can ask
for another 2000, so you
can go to that conference.
That's enabled the people --
because they have no
money to travel --
enabled those people in
those little places to come
to that conference and network
with others in the same shape,
and that's invaluable.
Very, very valuable.
And the nice thing there is
they get to meet the people
from Washington who
are the power brokers.
>> Guha Shankar: But I
think you're being generous
on the one hand to
ATALM and IMLS,
but you're also pointing out,
it seems to me, a lack or a gap
in terms of sustaining
that knowledgebase,
because ATALM meets once
a year, but then the rest
of the year what happens
in between meetings?
I mean, it seems to me
that there's something --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
unless they've encountered
somebody and interfaced
with them at the conference,
exchanged information,
got their emails,
probably not much.
But there's value in that, and I
think a number of them do that.
You've probably been
approached that way.
>> Judith Gray: Yeah.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
You know, once they know you
and they know they
can call you --
that happens on a
one-on-one basis,
and I expect a good
bit of that happens.
>> Guha Shankar: It does.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
More than I know.
The nice thing about
that conference is,
they pull in people
like yourselves,
people from various
government offices,
who are really unapproachable
to them out in those little --
Rough Rock, Arizona,
until they've met them
and they know they
can talk to them.
There are many -- I'm trying
to think of some that were --
I call them fringe,
like Parks Service.
There are many different federal
agencies that could have a role.
That's what I see LC
doing: having some element
from the various and many
departments, divisions,
I can see where -- even
the law library, you know,
has an indigenous law library
-- well that's invaluable,
because tribal people need the
law, and that's like them saying
to me, "We don't want to have
to go to the state and say,
"What does the state
statute say?"
We want to look it
up ourselves."
So this indigenous law
library component here --
I haven't explored it, so I
don't know much about it but --
and I don't know if anybody
from that office has come
to the ATALM meetings.
Have they?
>> Guha Shankar: Yes.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Good, good, okay.
>> Guha Shankar: Yeah.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: I am
so busy when I go to ATALM,
seeing people, and
renewing acquaintances
that I miss a lot
of the meetings.
But I'm out there, they all
know I'm there, you know?
I still get calls from
people wanting help
and I've also had calls,
like, from a mother
in Vermont whose sixth-grade
child has a report due on,
quote, "Indians" and could I
please sell them everything I
have on, quote, "Indians."
I'm usually patient with
them, but this time I wasn't.
I usually say, "Go to your
local public library."
And her response was,
"I don't have time."
So, I said, "Well what
makes you think I do?"
And I heard later
that I made her sick
and she had to go to the doctor.
So, you never know what
you're going to do or not do.
>> Guha Shankar: So I want
to ask you, circling back
to another point
you made earlier,
you talked about
New Mexico obviously
where you established the
tribal libraries forum
or the association -- that's
a shining moment it seems
to me in terms of success.
How have those, sort
of, relationships
and those foundations
you built --
how are they going on
today in New Mexico?
Are they continuing in terms
of training and librarianship?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Yes, and in New Mexico,
because we worked a lot
with the state library,
every time we got a new state
librarian, which was frequently,
I would call them and
say, "Let me take you out
and show you the
tribal libraries."
So you have to work at it.
And they, and then,
after I left,
one of the people I had
hired to do training
for me became -- guess what?
The state librarian.
So -- and Ben Wakashige
you've probably met.
They actually worked --
and Ben is a genius --
they got some state legislation,
we had a Navajo legislator --
that helps -- whose sister
was a librarian -- that helps.
But he introduced legislation
in the New Mexico legislature
to provide state funds
for tribal libraries.
That's as far as -- I
think New York did that,
Joe Schubert many years ago
did that in New York State.
But that was kind of a first;
most states won't do that,
where they allocated some
money for the tribal libraries.
But the thing is, in
those communities,
if they're white people, anybody
can come use the tribal library.
It's not just for Indians.
So it really is a
community library.
>> Guha Shankar: I was
curious, I mean, there's a point
that was made I think maybe
by one of your associates
that libraries, because they are
part of the education system,
are actually a sovereign
right, or a treaty right?
Can you expand a little --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
by treaty, with most tribes,
the federal government promised
the Indians, if they give
up all their land and move,
that the federal government
would provide them with health,
education and welfare.
Those three big things.
Well, you can fit libraries in
two of those and maybe three.
So they were what we call
"treaty obligations," and we use
that as saying, "You promised
that you would provide" --
and the schools are obvious.
Welfare's a broader term, but
I fit libraries into that.
And even health, because
NIH approached me once,
and "What can we do to work
with tribal libraries?"
They want to, they
want to do it.
But because tribes
do have a status
as being sovereign
nations within a nation,
they are -- they're sovereign.
Only thing on a reservation,
I've tried to explain
to some tourists -- when
you're on a reservation,
state laws do not apply.
Don't call the sheriff;
they can't help you
if you get in trouble.
You're on your own.
Tribal law applies.
The only thing that precedes
tribal law is federal law.
So, you know, I used to think,
when I crossed that line going
into a reservation, I even
took my sunglasses off
because I didn't want
to look like a tourist.
Hide your camera, get
rid of your camera.
You are their guest, and that's
the way I always looked at it.
I'm afraid that is not an
attitude some people understand,
but they -- that relationship
of federal responsibility
to sovereign nations within
a nation is very complicated.
That's why we have
high-paid tribal lawyers
and there are law firms here in
D.C. that only do tribal law.
But it's complicated, and
that's why the states, though,
state libraries can say, "Hey,
they're a federal
responsibility.
We don't owe them a thing.
We do not put state
money onto reservations,
even if it's training."
Now, that's less and
less true, I think.
Arizona has done things,
New Mexico, but some states
where there's a large Indian
population still feel that way.
>> Judith Gray: Including
Oklahoma?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Oklahoma --
here's their response, the state
librarian: "Well, they can come
to us and we'll help them."
Okay. They do training workshops
for their public librarians,
you know, the basic stuff.
"They can come to those."
Well, the little
tribal libraries are a
one-person library.
They can't take off, and if they
could, they don't have the money
to drive 200 miles
to Oklahoma City
and spend a night in a hotel.
They just can't do it.
So we have a mix, you
know, a mix and match.
Sometimes they will go to
those training sessions.
I would say in Oklahoma
they try to do,
the state library,
what they can.
But they will argue, "We
have to use state money,
you know, in a certain way.
The federal government
should do that."
It varies with the
state librarian,
who's the state librarian,
what their attitude is.
>> Judith Gray: And at
the university itself
in the library school, how much
of the training there does
end up for tribal people?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: None.
>> Judith Gray: So all the
time you were teaching there,
it was --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, think about it.
Universities, you know, are --
it's a graduate school program,
professors are all under the
gun to write and publish,
and to do something with tribal
libraries is taking their
own time.
It's something they could do,
and I would say they
really don't.
They might come to a
meeting now and then.
It's not that they don't support
them; it's just that they are
under the gun, fulfill
their role
as a researcher and a publisher.
And as I was told, if
they focused on Indians,
that's not going to
get them anywhere
in their tenure track,
generally speaking.
>> Judith Gray: Of
course, it did for you.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Well, you know,
you have to be really
stubborn, like I was,
[inaudible] say I'm
going to do it anyway.
But we do have -- the other
element I've sort of tried
to work on, is getting
Indian professors,
and we do have a few.
But we need more.
>> Guha Shankar:
You know, Lotsee,
you just mentioned something
about the fact that education
and that was part of the treaty,
you know, sort of obligation,
and I'm reminded that the
Esther Martinez language act
for Native Americans is
run through the Department
of Health and Human Services.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Yeah, that's right.
>> Guha Shankar: So
that's really interesting,
just sort of supporting your
point, that health, education
and welfare in terms of
education cuts across a lot
of different federal agencies.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yes,
and I think another valuable
thing for tribal libraries is
to know about those things.
I don't know how -- that's ANA
you're talking about, yeah.
There are, you know, among
your big federal agencies,
components that will work with
Indians, but who knows about it?
You know, how do
you know about it
and how do you know
to access that?
You know, I'll go
begging on the streets
if I think I can
find some money.
Or, not just money, but
it's more assistance,
because I think money
is ephemeral,
and you need the
people connection.
And I've always said, you
can start a library anywhere
and watch it grow.
I've started them anywhere,
and I get really, really tired
of people who say, "Oh, we
don't have money for that."
Stop it! Just go do it!
Just do it!
>> Judith Gray: Sounds like --
>> Guha Shankar: Yeah.
So what are your
present projects?
What are you working on that's
sort of right on the top
of your -- besides
the homework you have
to do for the librarian?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Yeah.
>> Guha Shankar: What else
are you most involved with?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
I'm involved as an advisor
on this Oklahoma project
with Sam Noble Museum.
I'm not doing much advising
because they know what they're
doing, so they don't need me.
But I'm cheerleading.
You know, I think now
I have more opportunity
to one-on-one with people.
I still get calls
occasionally from people
and I appreciate their
effort and I never,
never am impatient
with the Indian.
I am sometimes impatient with
mothers of sixth-graders, but --
just the level of
stupidity, I'm sorry --
there's no other way to say it.
You know, first of all to say,
"We need everything you
have about Indians."
Go to the Library of Congress
and see how many
floors it covers.
The other thing I guess I would
say all of us should do is try
to promote good writing, you
know, people who write --
I don't care if it's
non-fiction or fiction.
We need people who write
from a perspective --
from the right perspective.
And it doesn't have
to be Indian,
but it has to be somebody who
understands and appreciates.
We need more and more people
telling their own story,
the Native people.
I've worked on that for years,
too, trying to encourage,
without much success,
I must say.
I've had book publisher,
editors, offer to help.
"Tell me someone,
I'll work with them."
And I've tried, but it
really doesn't take root.
There are very few authors that
can write a good fiction book
and there are people
who write non-fiction,
which I say it has
enough fiction in it
to satisfy my need for fiction.
>> Guha Shankar: So you're
working on a memoir then?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Huh?
>> Guha Shankar: Are
you working on a memoir?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: No,
but I have written my obituary.
Would you like to have a copy?
[ Laughter ]
>> Judith Gray: Only later.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: I plan
ahead, you know, I plan ahead.
Well, at 86 you need to!
And I will encounter
somebody once in a while
that I think might be interested
and I link them with editors.
Publishers are really, really --
I haven't done so much lately,
but they want to find
people who can do that.
Some of you all help
me with that.
You must meet people
that can do that.
>> Guha Shankar: Yes, sure.
We'll give you some names.
Well, we're going to come to
the end of our time with you
and we wanted to thank you,
and I guess the final, sort of,
question is, is there something
that we should have asked
or that you'd like to share
with us before we bring
this interview to a close?
What's on your mind, I mean?
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
I think I've told you more
than you wanted to know!
>> Guha Shankar: No.
>> Judith Gray: No, no.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
So, that's a good question.
I hadn't thought about that.
I guess I would just implore you
in your positions of influence
and expertise to do everything
you can, no matter how small,
to move things forward.
Also and backward, you know, the
preservation and conservation,
as well as looking
ahead, because the ahead
and the future -- you know,
so many people think
Indians are, like, gone.
No. I've taken people, you know,
want to go to Indian country,
"Well, where are the Indians?"
"Well you've just been
passing them on the sidewalk,
you didn't know that?"
You know, so education --
you're in a position to educate
both the Indian and non-Indian,
or indigenous, I guess.
So keep up the good
work, keep up the fight.
>> Guha Shankar: Great, okay.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: I'm
preaching to the choir I know.
>> Guha Shankar: It's always
good to get reinforcement
for our work, so
thank you for that.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Well,
and know that someone
appreciates it.
You may think day to day
nobody cares but we do.
We do.
>> Guha Shankar: Thank you.
>> Judith Gray: Thank you.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
And no matter how little,
it can be significant.
You never know you've
touched someone,
or just a very innocuous little
sentence leads to bigger things.
So do it. Just do it!
>> Judith Gray: Thank
you, Lotsee.
>> Guha Shankar: That'll be the
last word from our guest today,
Dr. Lotsee Patterson, and we
thank you so much for your time.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Thank you.
>> Guha Shankar: We have had
an interview with you here
at the Library of Congress
studio on December 20th.
Looking forward to having
more time with you --
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Might
give the year, December 20th --
>> Guha Shankar: 2017.
You're correct, thank
you so much.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson: Okay.
>> Guha Shankar: We're
still being educated
by [inaudible] doctor.
Thank you.
We really appreciate your time.
>> Dr. Lotsee Patterson:
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.